la camiseta de un bebé se fabrica con
cuatro quintos metros de tela cuántas
camisetas se pueden hacer si tenemos 48
metros de tela entonces tal cual lo que
queremos hacer es dividir a estos 48
metros de tela en pequeños grupos que
midan cuatro quintos de metros de tela
porque esa cantidad de grupos es la
cantidad de camisetas de bebé que
podemos hacer aunque entonces tomamos
los 48 metros y lo vamos a dividir en
grupos de tamaño 4 quintos de tela
porque por cada cuatro quintos de metros
de tela podemos hacer una camiseta de
bebé entonces esto de aquí es la
cantidad de camisetas de bebé que vamos
a poder hacer entonces vamos a hacer
esta división lo cual es igual pues a
ver siempre que estemos dividiendo entre
una fracción eso es exactamente
equivalente a multiplicar por el
recíproco de esa fracción
tenemos que multiplicar 48 por el
recíproco de cuatro quintos que es cinco
cuartos y ahora para hacer esta
multiplicación que es de un número
entero por una fracción pues lo más
fácil es recordar que todos los enteros
se pueden escribir como fracción aunque
para escribir 48 como fracción lo único
que tenemos que hacer es poner 48 entre
1 y lo estamos multiplicando por cinco
cuartos
y aquí pues podríamos multiplicar los
numeradores y dividir entre la
multiplicación de los denominadores pero
es mucho más fácil si de una vez
dividimos el numerador y el denominador
entre 4 bueno pero damos por partes aquí
esta multiplicación es igual a 48 por 5
entre 1 x 4 que es 4 y ahora si
dividimos el numerador entre 4 entonces
nos queda haber 48 entre 4 es 12
y 4 entre 4 pues es 1 entonces esta
fracción nos queda igual a haber 12 por
5 son 60
estos 60 viene de aquí de 12 por 5 y en
el denominador tenemos un 1 por aquí
está nuestro 1 pero resulta que 60 entre
1 es simplemente 60 y eso lo que nos
dice es que podemos hacer 60 camisetas
de bebé con 48 metros de tela si
necesitamos cuatro quintos metros de
tela para construir cada camiseta